the coronavirus pandemic is showing no
signs of slowing down with global deaths
expected to hit 2 million today
even as countries race to vaccinate
their populations the covet 19 death
toll continues to rise at an alarming
rate
new strains of the coronavirus which
scientists believe are more
transmissible
have been blamed for the surge in
infections across the world countries
are facing a second or even third wave
of infections
with many governments tightening even
further the lockdowns already in place
one country that's been plunged into
crisis by a new strain of the
coronavirus is the united kingdom
there the number of cases and deaths has
been skyrocketing since december
many hospitals are overwhelmed with
covert patients and as a result are no
longer able to carry out
other operations as dw's charlotte
chelsea pill reports this is taking a
huge toll
mentally and physically both on the
population and the medical workers
trying to save lives i've never seen
so many ambulances queuing and i've
never spent such
extended periods of time with people
waiting for a space
[Music]
over the last three four weeks the
majority of patients are now
coronavirus takes a nice deep breath
every region in england has more people
in hospital now than they did
in the first wave in the spring in our
case we've gone up by double the number
of patients we're still in london
admitting the equivalent of a really big
hospital
every single day whilst having higher
numbers of staff
and frontline staff who are off sick or
isolating or tested positive themselves
i've just finished 10 days of isolation
because my wife tested positive
so she's also a paramedic the personal
protective equipment that we were
wearing was from our perspective not
quite enough
and a number of our friends and
colleagues were in the same situation
and
they've also tested positive over the
last few weeks
i think the impact of the new variant
has been immense
it is just more infectious you know 50
more infectious where we were beginning
of december thinking we had
weathered the storm suddenly we've had a
surge in numbers
so huge we couldn't have imagined it
would be
as bad and that's because this new
spread so easily spreads like wildfire
and it's caught us a lot by surprise the
new variant just made it absolutely
explode
um and again you know we waited too long
to stamp down on it there's still more
to come from this wave of the pandemic
well we expect the mortality will go
up and we're seeing far more people
being admitted to intensive care units
that are now becoming overwhelmed a lot
of hospitals in the south east are now
cancelling what are called
28-day cancer surgeries the people
who've had their surgeries cancelled
are now having to wait at home knowing
that their tumor's growing
and for some of them by the time it's
safe again they might not be operable
anymore
and that they've lost that window you
know so i mean that
to me is a kind of a kind of a mental
torture
you know a lot of people that find it
very tough one of my friends said you
know he was just helping someone a
colleague having a panic attack the
other day
that people are having nightmares about
it the really hard thing about being
stuck at hospital for five hours is that
all the time that you're there you're
hearing
your colleagues in the control room
asking for ambulances to be available to
get you to
other emergencies into people that need
your help and you can't go
they're constantly in a situation where
they know they're not doing the best for
their patients or they're trying their
best
but they're just not in a position to be
able to do that and that's something
that people are wrestling with
quite a lot is knowing that you know
they might have been able to do some
more or if they have arrived
earlier than they they might have been
able to
um change the outcome for a particular
patient i'm sure it's having a toll up
and down the country but
i don't think we have a choice we just
do our best to carry on that's what
we're trained
we're trained to do and you know i'm
very
privileged to work with people who feel
that way it's hard
and it's it's taken its toll but we know
that we're doing the best we can in the
circumstances
and if we didn't go out then more people
would die and would suffer as a result
of of not having
people working on the front line
meanwhile germany has passed the two
million mark in recorded coronavirus
cases
it comes as chancellor angela merkel
pushes for a stricter lockdown
merkel has told top officials from her
party that she wants quick action to
stop the spread of worrying
new coronavirus variants
well in other developments in the
pandemic france is to impose a
nationwide 6pm curfew starting on
saturday
from next week everyone traveling to
france from outside the european union
will have to show a negative test and
then isolate for seven days
the uk has banned travelers from south
america and portugal over concerns about
a virus variant that has emerged in
brazil
it comes as brazil's health minister
says hospitals in the amazonian city of
manuels
are running out of oxygen to treat
covert 19 patients